- Alexandre Poussart:
Bonjour à tous.
Bienvenue dans un nouveau numéro
de "Parlement hebdo".
Heureux de vous retrouver.
L'émission revient
sur les temps forts
de la semaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder:
Nous accueillons Mathilde Panot.
Bonjour.
Merci d'être notre invitée.
- Alexandre Poussart:
A la une, le projet
de loi immigration examiné.
Les députés ont rétabli
l'aide médicale d'Etat
qui avait été restreinte
par le Sénat.
Ils ont aussi
modifié l'article
sur la régularisation
des travailleurs
sans papiers
dans les métiers en tension.
L'Assemblée a adopté
deux propositions
de loi portées
par La France Insoumise
pour créer
une commission d'enquête
sur la gestion
des risques naturels
en outre-mer et pour couvrir
des accueils physiques
dans les services publics.
La mort du jeune Thomas
à Crépol continue
de faire réagir
les parlementaires.
Des députés et sénateurs
ont dénoncé l'expédition punitive
organisée en réaction à ce drame
à Romans-sur-Isère.
- Kathia Gilder:
Les députés ont poursuivi l'examen
du projet de loi.
Ils ont réécrit l'article visant
à améliorer l'intégration
en ouvrant la voie
à des régularisations
de travailleurs
sans-papiers
dans des métiers en tension.
L'Assemblée a réécrit certaines
autres dispositions
qui avaient été votées au Sénat.
- C'est le coeur du débat,
la régularisation
des travailleurs
sans papiers qui travaillent
dans les métiers en tension.
Cet article
avait été modifié
par le Sénat.
Les députés ont voté
une version
de compromis.
Cette régularisation ne sera
ni un droit automatique
ni un pouvoir
discrétionnaire du préfet.
- Un dispositif resserré
permet de tirer
de l'illégalité
et des conditions inacceptables
de maltraitance
des ressortissants
en situation irrégulière.
- Le préfet pourra
refuser de donner
une carte de séjour
sur les étrangers
qui ne respectent pas
les valeurs
de la République.
Un compromis
qui ne satisfait
ni la droite ni l'extrême droite.
- Le droit de veto sera
encadré et difficile.
Régulariser les métiers
en tension,
c'est amorcer
une pompe inépuisable.
Nous sommes opposés
aux dispositions
de l'article.
- C'est un appel d'air.
Là où c'est grave,
c'est que vous prévoyez
la régularisation
de gens
qui n'ont pas respecté
les lois
de la République.
- Pour la gauche,
c'est tout sauf
un compromis.
- L'appel n'existe pas.
C'est un mythe complet.
- Il est le refus
de régulariser
des travailleurs
qui payent des impôts.
- Autre sujet inflammable,
l'aide médicale d'Etat.
Le Sénat l'avait
supprimé au grand regret
du camp présidentiel.
Les députés l'ont rétabli.
Dès le premier
jour de débat,
ils ont supprimé les quotas
d'immigration économique
que les sénateurs
avaient instaurés.
- Kathia Gilder:
Suppression des quotas
d'immigration,
rétablissement de l'AME,
l'Assemblée a refait
un texte proche
de ce qui avait été
proposé au début.
Vous saluez la volonté
de la majorité
de vouloir
trouver un texte
le plus équilibré possible?
- Mathilde Panot: Pas du tout.
On conteste le fait qu'il y ait
un énième texte immigration.
C'est la 22e loi
sur l'immigration
depuis 1990.
Contrairement à beaucoup
d'autres lois,
ces lois n'ont
jamais été évalué
sur leur bilan.
Pourquoi?
Lorsque l'on parle
d'immigration,
la question
n'est pas de savoir
ce que ça produit,
mais de montrer notamment
à l'extrême droite
et à la droite,
on le voit ici,
comment le débat reste tiré
par ces idées propagées
très fortement
dans le champ
politique, de montrer
qu'on fait
quelque chose pour dire
qu'on a fait quelque chose.
- Kathia Gilder:
Il n'y a pas de sincérité
du débat?
- Mathilde Panot:
Ce n'est pas le problème
quand on propage
des paroles xénophobes,
et racistes.
Je ne sais pas
si vous avez entendu
le sénateur
Reconquête au Sénat
qui expliquait que,
par exemple,
"on ne pouvait pas naître
comme un veau
dans une écurie
et devenir un cheval".
Je vous laisse
apprécier la qualité
de l'intervention.
Vous avez des paroles
racistes qui s'expriment
comme ça et vous avez une vision
globale
de ce qui se passe dans le monde.
Nous ne sommes pas,
contrairement
à ce qui est dit,
sous un flux migratoire
en France.
La plupart
de l'immigration
dans le monde
sont des flux sud-sud.
C'est la première chose.
Ensuite, l'extrême
droite, la droite
et les macronistes
qui sont les premiers
à pointer du doigt
les exilés
de ce pays, sont ceux
aussi qui adorent
les traités de libre-échange
qui détruisent
les agricultures
vivrières, acceptent
que l'Etat fabrique
des sans-papiers.
Comme vous avez des corps
préfectoraux
qui ne peuvent pas
suivre,
vous vous retrouvez
avec des gens
en situation régulière
qui deviennent
en situation irrégulière.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Quand certains étrangers
dans notre pays
qui sont condamnés
pour des délits
ne peuvent pas
être expulsés,
car ils ont des protections,
est-ce que c'est un problème?
- Mathilde Panot:
Il y a des dispositions
pour pouvoir expulser
des gens lorsque
la loi n'est pas respectée.
Ca existe.
Il n'y a pas besoin
d'une énième loi
pour ça.
J'aimerais
qu'on ne parle pas juste
des exilés.
Je le dis pour le débat
public général.
Je le dis, les personnes
sans papiers
sont celles qui
vont vous emmener
vos colis, celles qui lavent
vos bureaux...
- Alexandre Poussart:
Certains
ne peuvent pas
être expulsés,
dans les délinquants.
- Mathilde Panot:
Vous avez le phénomène
des ni expulsables
ni régularisables.
Je parle des personnes
sans papiers
de manière générale.
Ils ne sont pas
expulsables,
parce que les pays
dont ils sont originaires
ne sont pas sûrs parfois.
On ne va pas renvoyer
quelqu'un en zone
de guerre.
Ou alors,
ils rentrent pas
dans les critères
de régularisation.
Vous vous retrouvez
avec des situations
où des gens
ont passé 90 jours
dans des centres
de rétention admirative
en ayant parfois rien fait.
Ce sont des situations
qui sont des impasses.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le fait qu'un étranger
soit arrivé
sur notre sol avant un certain
âge peut être un critère
d'expulsion...
- Mathilde Panot: Je ne pense pas.
Ce sont des criminels français.
Ils doivent faire de la prison.
- Kathia Gilder:
Est-ce que, Mathilde Panot,
un étranger, dans ce cas,
doit remplir
des devoirs pour vivre
sur notre sol
comme parler a minima
notre langue
et respecter les valeurs
de la République?
-
Mathilde Panot:
C'est ce qu'il se passe
déjà actuellement.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On pourrait faire
un examen de français.
- Mathilde Panot:
Je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ça.
Je vais vous dire
la réalité de beaucoup
de familles
qui se trouvent
sur notre territoire
en situation irrégulière.
Ca fait deux ans
que je lutte aux côtés
des travailleurs
de Chronopost
qui sont par sous-traitance
des travailleurs employés
par La Poste.
Le directeur de La Poste l'assume.
Il explique que ça fait
de la concurrence,
il faut faire en sorte
que les conditions
de travail et les salaires
soient tirés
par le bas
pour continuer de faire
ce qu'ils font.
L'Etat est actionnaire
majoritaire
de La Poste.
L'Etat sait
donc
ce qui est en train de se passer.
Il y avait eu
73 régularisations en 2009.
Il connaît la situation
et accepte
que des entreprises
par sous-traitance
comme La Poste emploie
les travailleurs
sans papiers.
Quand vous faites
la régularisation
de tous les travailleurs
sans papiers,
cela remonte
les conditions de travail
et les salaires de tout le monde.
Sur la médicale d'Etat,
c'est une politique
de santé publique.
- Kathia Gilder: Ca a été rétabli.
- Mathilde Panot: Heureusement!
- Alexandre Poussart:
Pourquoi les insoumis
ne défendent pas l'article
du projet
de loi qui prévoit
ou prévoyait initialement
une régularisation automatique
des travailleurs
sans papiers
dans les métiers en tension?
D'autres défendent cet article.
- Mathilde Panot:
Nous défendons
la régularisation de tous
les travailleurs
sans papiers.
Il y a deux choses
qui nous posent problème
dans la version
actuellement discutée.
Les titres de séjour
sont seulement donnés
pour un an.
Si vous parlez
à qui que ce
soit en préfecture,
vous comprenez
que vu le manque
de moyens qu'ont
les préfectures,
eux-mêmes demandent
à ce qu'on passe
des titres de séjour
de 5 ans ou 10 ans
qui permettent
que l'Etat
ne fabrique pas des sans-papiers
du fait de l'absence de réponse.
Ensuite, vous allez
avoir une liste
de métiers en tension
qui, du jour
au lendemain,
pourra être changée
et qui pourra remettre des gens
en irrégularité.
Avec cet article,
vous avez des gens
qui seraient jetables.
Nous réfutons cela.
Nous nous battons
pour la régularisation
de tous les travailleurs
sans papiers.
- Kathia Gilder:
L'ambiance est houleuse
dans la commission des lois.
Ugo Bernalicis a provoqué
une altercation
avec un autre député.
Il demandait
une suspension de séance
pour assister
dans l'hémicycle
à la discussion de vos textes LFI.
Est-ce qu'il a dérapé?
- Mathilde Panot:
Ugo Bernalicis s'est levé.
Il n'a été violent avec personne.
Lors de notre niche
parlementaire...
- Alexandre Poussart:
Ce n'est pas violent d'attraper
le bras de quelqu'un?
- Mathilde Panot:
Je n'étais pas là.
Il s'est levé,
il a parlé fort
et il a exigé...
C'est le seul
jour dans l'année
où on peut choisir
l'ordre du jour,
les niches parlementaires.
Il y a des commissions
qui se tiennent
en même temps.
On avait commencé
un texte qui dépend
de la commission
des lois
et il y avait un
engagement
à ce que ce
soit arrêté
pour que les commissaires
de loi puissent
être en hémicycle.
Yaël Braun-Pivet
est la présidente
de l'Assemblée
qui a donné
le plus de sanctions
de l'histoire
de la Ve République.
- Kathia Gilder:
On va parler des textes
à l'ordre du jour.
Vous avez disposé
de l'ordre du jour
de 9h à minuit.
Deux propositions
de loi
que vous avez défendues
ont été adoptées
dont l'une pour créer
une commission d'enquête
sur les risques
naturels en outre-mer
et l'autre pour réinstaurer
un accueil physique
dans les services publics.
- Les outils numériques
sont porteurs
de progrès
dans de nombreux domaines.
Par contre,
lorsqu'ils participent
à des politiques
de restriction budgétaire
et s'accompagnent du recul
des implantations territoriales,
la numérisation
publique conduit
des ruptures
d'accès au droit
pour une part de la population.
- Kathia Gilder:
Votre texte a été adopté
contre l'avis du gouvernement.
Qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez?
- Mathilde Panot:
C'est une victoire
très importante
que la victoire
sur ce texte.
Parce que les services
publics
sont le patrimoine
de ceux qui n'ont rien
dans ce pays
et que la dématérialisation
accompagnée de la disparition
des accueils physiques
et de la possibilité
de parler
à un être humain
mettent gravement
en danger l'égalité
des citoyens
devant la République.
On parle de 20%
de personnes
qui ont du mal à accéder
au service public.
Il y a 8 millions
de personnes
qui sont en situation
de d'illectronisme
dans ce pays.
C'est un texte extrêmement large.
Si cela a été adopté,
les macronistes
n'ont pas osé
voter contre,
c'est parce que chacun
sait
que cela répond
à une réalité du pays,
que ce soit dans des zones
rurales,
des quartiers
populaires ou partout,
il y a un effondrement
du service public tel
et une réduction
du nombre d'agents
du service
public qui font
qu'ils n'ont pas réussi
à empêcher
que cette proposition
de loi passe.
J'en suis très heureuse.
J'espère qu'elle passera au Sénat.
J'espère qu'elle pourra
s'appliquer.
-
Alexandre Poussart:
Est-ce que vous
avez des garanties
de vos collègues
sénateurs de gauche
qui pourraient
reprendre votre texte?
Que dites-vous
à la majorité de droite
du Sénat?
- Mathilde Panot:
Les Républicains,
de par les territoires
où ils sont élus,
sont sensibles à cette question.
Quand on parle
de cette question
de problème d'accès
aux services publics,
on va parler
de la question de l'accès
au minimum vieillesse,
d'allocations familiales,
de choses
très concrètes d'accès
à des droits
et des papiers
pour les personnes
en situation irrégulière.
Nous allons
prendre contact
avec les groupes du Sénat.
Nous ne l'avons pas encore fait.
C'était
une victoire
que nous avons vraiment arrachée.
- Kathia Gilder:
C'était inattendu?
- Mathilde Panot:
J'avais bon espoir
de commencer la journée
par la victoire
sur la commission
d'enquête
sur les risques
majeurs en outre-mer,
qui est un thème très large.
Je n'étais pas sûre
qu'on arrive
à en arroger d'autres.
- Kathia Gilder:
On vous a entendue
dans l'hémicycle.
Vous avez félicité le fait
que l'Assemblée adopte
le principe
de cette commission d'enquête
sur la gestion
des risques naturels
en outre-mer.
En quoi ces risques sont mal
gérés aujourd'hui?
On parle de tornades,
de cyclones...
- Mathilde Panot:
L'Etat a failli,
mais c'est un débat
de société
plus large que l'on devrait mener.
Aucun Etat aujourd'hui
n'est à la hauteur
du plus grand défi
de notre siècle
qui est le dérèglement climatique.
Comme génération
humaine,
je ne parle pas d'âge,
personne n'a eu
à affronter un aussi
gros problème
et une aussi
grosse rupture
avec nos modèles
de production
et de consommation.
Ceux -- Ce à quoi
sont confrontés
nos compatriotes
ultramarins,
c'est d'être en première ligne
du dérèglement climatique.
Il y a un risque cyclonique,
sismique, volcanique,
de sécheresse...
- Kathia Gilder:
C'est plus fort
en outre-mer?
- Mathilde Panot:
Oui, et en plus,
certains territoires
sont insulaires.
La montée des eaux qui atteint
certaines communes,
je pense à la Martinique...
Je suis heureuse
de cette commission d'enquête.
Il faut réfléchir
quel doit
être le rôle de l'Etat
pour faire face
et protéger nos compatriotes
ultramarins
qui sont en première ligne.
Ce sont aussi des conclusions
qui doivent aider
le pays tout entier.
Ce à quoi
elles sont confrontées,
nous y sommes déjà
confrontés,
mais nous y serons
encore plus confrontés
à l'avenir en Hexagone,
c'est faire oeuvre d'intérêt
général et faire
en sorte qu'on apprenne
de la France des océans.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On va parler
du drame de Crépol
et de ses suites.
La mort du jeune
Thomas continue
de faire réagir
les parlementaires,
notamment après l'expédition
punitive organisée
en réaction par l'ultra droite.
C'était à Romans-sur-Isère
le week-end dernier.
Retour sur les vives réactions.
- Mardi, Gérald
Darmanin affiche
sa fermeté.
Il va dissoudre les groupuscules
d'extrême droite auteurs
de violences
après la mort de Thomas.
- Des moyens
nombreux sont mis
pour poursuivre
les personnes radicalisées
de l'ultra droite
pour les interpeller,
pour engager les procédures
de dissolution,
comme je l'ai fait
avec Génération Identitaire.
- Des sanctions
bien accueillies
au Sénat, mais qui laissent
un goût amer
sur les bancs de la droite.
Pour Bruno Retailleau,
la réponse
n'est pas suffisante.
- Il ne faut pas que l'exécutif
se réfugie
derrière ces groupes
d'extrême droite
pour échapper à la vraie
signification
de Crépol.
Quand vous écoutez
les gens,
ce qu'ils veulent,
c'est que la France silencieuse
qui ne crée pas de problèmes,
qui élève
ses enfants,
puisse être reconnue
et que justice soit faite.
- Pour la gauche non plus,
la dissolution
des groupuscules ne suffit pas.
La gauche demande
des sanctions d'inéligibilité
contre ceux qui
instrumentalisent
ces incidents.
-
Derrière ces mobilisations,
il y a des donneurs d'ordre
et des responsables politiques
qui créent ce climat
de guerre civile.
Je vise par exemple
Marion Maréchal,
Eric Zemmour, Marine Le Pen...
Le sang de Thomas
était encore chaud
que ces gens créaient ce climat
de guerre civile.
- La dissolution des groupuscules
sera prononcée mercredi 6 décembre
lors du prochain
Conseil des ministres.
-
Alexandre Poussart:
Est-ce que le gouvernement
est assez ferme
avec ces groupuscules?
- Mathilde Panot:
On avait alerté
dès 2019 en demandant
une commission d'enquête
sur la question
de la lutte
contre les groupuscules
d'extrême droite.
Je crois
que le gouvernement
n'a pas pris
la conscience
de ce qui se passe
et notamment
des seuils
qui sont franchis
dans notre pays
et du grand danger
que représente
l'extrême droit
avec des groupuscules
qui se sentent
en forte impunité,
notamment,
parce que quelqu'un
comme Eric Ciotti
a du mal à condamner
l'expédition punitive
à Romans-sur-Isère,
mais aussi
parce des politiques
comme Eric Zemmour
ne cessent d'expliquer
que l'islam
n'est pas compatible
avec la République.
Ils autorisent ce type de parole.
A Romans-sur-Isère,
ils criaient
que l'islam devait
être en dehors
de l'Europe.
Une forme d'impunité se crée.
Il faut prendre
la conscience
de ce qui se passe.
C'est bien de faire
des dissolutions illustratives,
mais je n'ai pas eu
la réponse
à une question que j'ai posée.
Comment se fait-il
que ces groupuscules
se soient retrouvés
en disposition
des noms et prénoms
des suspects
de la mort de Thomas,
de leur adresse,
de leurs numéros
de téléphone et de membres
de leur famille?
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il y aurait
des fuites dans la police?
- Mathilde Panot:
Il y a forcément
des fuites quelque part.
- Kathia Gilder:
Des fuites
dans la police ou plus haut?
- Mathilde Panot:
C'est grave
si des groupuscules
d'extrême droite peuvent
avoir accès à ce type
d'informations.
Nous avons eu de la chance
à Romans-sur-Isère.
La population a fait preuve
d'un sang-froid incroyable.
Cela peut tourner au drame.
Lorsque
que nous avons à l'université
de Bordeaux, Louis Boyard
qui se retrouve,
alors qu'il fait
un meeting
avec des jeunes,
à avoir 30 personnes d'extrême
droite cagoulées
avec des barres
de fer, je le dis,
nous passons
des seuils inquiétants
et nous devons
en prendre les mesures.
Nous nous battrons
contre l'extrême droit
à chaque instant.
-
Kathia Gilder:
Quelques jours avant ces
événements, Thomas
a été poignardé
à mort,
alors qu'il assistait
à un bal communal.
Est-ce que ce drame
est le signe
de deux France
qui s'opposent,
la France des quartiers
contre la France
des villages,
comme le dit la droite?
- Mathilde Panot:
Il ne faut pas rentrer dedans.
Je veux saluer la dignité
incroyable d'une famille touchée
par un drame aussi
profond que la mort
de leur fils,
qui a demandé instamment
lors de la marche
blanche, qu'il n'y
ait pas
d'instrumentalisation
de la mort de leur fils
et qu'ils puissent faire
leur deuil correctement.
Si vous commencez à parler
d'une opposition
entre la France
des villages et la France
des quartiers populaires,
comme essayer
de -- essayent
de le faire certains
députés d'extrême droite...
Tout comme opposer
nos compatriotes
de confession musulmane,
de confession chrétienne,
de confession juive...
Le peuple français
n'a pas de religion.
Vous entrez dans une forme
de guerre civile
que veulent instaurer
l'extrême droite
et la droite,
qui est très dangereuse.
A tout moment,
nous devons
être les gardiens
de l'unité de la nation.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Pour vous,
ce n'est pas une réalité?
Le ministre
de l'Intérieur a dit
qu'on avait évité
"une petite guerre civile".
Ce n'est pas une réalité,
cette opposition?
- Mathilde Panot:
Quand je vous dis
que c'est grave,
ce qui s'est passé
à Romans-sur-Isère,
comme le drame
de la mort
d'un jeune homme
et tout cela.
Je dis que nous avons échappé
au pire,
parce que la question
est de savoir...
Vous avez vu
les paroles tenues
dans notre République?
C'est très grave.
Il faut savoir comment faire
peuple ensemble.
J'aimerais que l'on discute
de comment
on peut faire
pour que tout le monde puisse
avoir une vie
digne et qu'il n'y
ait pas autant
de pauvres dans ce pays.
Comment faire face
au dérèglement climatique,
plus grand défi de notre siècle?
Voilà ce qui devrait
lier les gens
entre eux.
- Kathia Gilder:
Comment vous expliquez l'ultra
violence de ces jeunes,
souvent
très jeunes, qui arrivent
en bande armée?
- Mathilde Panot:
Malheureusement,
ce n'est pas nouveau.
Si vous lisez certains
de vos confrères
qui racontent les personnes
qui sévissaient
à Paris avec des phénomènes
d'ultra violence,
c'était en 1900.
- Kathia Gilder:
Comment arrêter
ce genre de dérive?
- Mathilde Panot:
La première chose,
c'est qu'il faut que justice
soit faite lorsqu'il
y a des drames.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous réclamez
de la fermeté?
- Mathilde Panot:
Je réclame le respect
de l'Etat de droit
et de la justice.
Deuxième chose,
il ne vous a pas échappé
que notre société
est malade de savoir
quel avenir on lui réserve.
Je reproche
au gouvernement actuel,
à Marine Le Pen,
qui est l'assurance vie
du système,
de bloquer l'avenir,
la perspective
de se projeter
dans des choses.
Le fait que l'éducation
n'ait pas assez
de moyens a des impacts concrets.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Eric Dupond-Moretti
a été relaxé
par la cour de justice.
Les insoumis dénoncent
un arrangement
entre les parlementaires
de la majorité
et de la droite
dont étaient composés
les juges de la CJR.
- Mathilde Panot:
"Je dirais
que la Cour
de justice
de la République
donne l'impression
que l'affaire concernant
les ministres
se résout par des petits
arrangements
entre amis."
La décision de le relaxer est
un bras d'honneur à la justice.
- Kathia Gilder:
Merci, Mathilde Panot.
C'est la fin de cette mission.
A bientôt.